they're fighting a war here and they're
losing the sheer numbers of people
succumbing to the coronavirus is
overwhelming every hospital in northern
Italy
the staff are working flat-out trying to
keep these people from deteriorating
further they're trying to stop them from
dying this isn't an intensive care unit
it's an emergency ward the ICU is full
people have only just arrived here and
they're in terrible shape this is an
absolute constant this killer pandemic
is virtually out of control the patients
are literally gasping for air
[Music]
the plastic bubbles the staff struggle
to communicate through attempt to
equalize the air pressure in the lungs
[Music]
nobody expected this nobody thought
they'd be treating so many so quickly
and it's not like flu it is chronic
pneumonia and it is killing hundreds
each day there are now all 15 patients
the doctors say they've seen nothing
like it before and a warning other
countries especially the United Kingdom
that they will see it as well people
have keep describing this is like flu
it's worse than that no it's not only
another thing I think it must know more
Nia mostly money than than flu because
most people get pneumonia and as I said
before it's a very severe pneumonia and
so it's a massive massive strain for for
every Health System because we see every
day 50 to 60 patients who come to our
reverse the pattern pneumonia and most
of them are so severe they they need
very high fio2 or oxygen and so it's we
have to reorganize our emergency room
and our hospital in three levels of
intensity as you see so this is the main
hospital in Bergamo in lumbering
province
it's one of the most advanced
but it's the most hard-hit of all the
hospitals in Italy but town is the
center of the epidemic here
[Music]
this isn't a ward this is a waiting room
wherever you go people are on Gurney's
in corridors and meeting rooms they're
everywhere all the medical staff urge
other nations to see what's happening
and lock their Nations down right now or
face this what I would suggest is just
shut down to stop all the outbreak and
not coming this kind of situation that
is very very difficult to manage can you
tell me what it's been like
I never feel so stressed in my life I
intensivist and I quite used to you know
in intense movement and choices and
people are critical and will die without
any you know treatment and you make the
difference but when you're at this point
you realize that you are not enough and
maybe all the we are 100 honest this
year we are doing our best but maybe
it's not it's not enough to the
Cannavaro see the problem facing health
services across the world is that when
the infection curve goes up it Rockets
and all the resources all the testing
all the supplies are used up instantly
multiple hospitals all at once
what's staggering is that Italy is doing
a lot a lot of testing thousands upon
thousands
so far about 4,000 the numbers keep
changing have actually completely
recovered the crucial point is of about
the same number a die they're sort of
neck-and-neck and it seems that you
either live and recover something nobody
Bergamo wanted us to see this to show
what a catastrophic emergency
nobody has experienced before looks like
here they're calling it the apocalypse
and this is what it looks like their
message to us is simple get ready
still Ramsey Sky News Bergamo it
[Music]